Bueno ya llega nuestro primer repaso
económico de la mañana para ello nos
acompaña nuestra compañera Daniela
hablandon Dani bienvenida Muchas gracias
bienvenido también Rodri Gracias Daniela
vamos a empezar hablando de la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
fonder Legend que ha estado de viaje por
América Latina y ha cerrado ese viaje
Así que cuéntanos que ha conseguido
claro lo veíamos con nuestro
corresponsal Mario carbonel que es su
última parada fue en Ciudad de México de
donde Úrsula Thunder Legend y el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
convinieron a apresurar la firma de un
tratado de libre comercio antes de
finales de este año esto a pesar de las
restricciones las fricciones mejor que
hay entre ambos sobre todo en torno a
las políticas de transición energética
que son bastante polémicas en el caso
mexicano también la postura frente a la
invasión rusa de Ucrania ahora si damos
un repaso por todo lo que fue este viaje
antes de México
Brasil en donde comprometió recursos
para el cuidado de la amazonía después
se detuvo en chile y Argentina vemos
como allí prometió también inversiones
En energías renovables y en litio
después en México por supuesto los que
hablábamos del tratado de libre comercio
pero en general para toda la región la
alta ejecutiva comunitaria anunció
inversiones por más de 10 mil millones
de dólares en proyectos sostenibles y
dijo que promoverá el visto bueno del
final
del acuerdo comercial con mercosur que
está estancado Hace 4 años en el
parlamento europeo parece Dani que la
renovables y la energía en general ha
sido un punto clave ahora que Rusia
parece dar problemas también a la Unión
Europea claro y la Unión Europea Está
tratando de hacer esa transición y
necesita las materias primas que tenemos
aquí en América Latina pues veremos Cómo
sigue este nuevo esta nueva amistad
realizada entre la Unión Europea y la
región nos vamos ahora hasta china pero
hablamos también de la Unión Europea
porque han reavivado
las potencias sus asperezas comerciales
claro es que mientras acá son los nuevos
mejores amigos pues no pasa lo mismo con
china el comisionado para industria de
la comisión europea tierra y bretón y
instó el jueves a más países del bloque
comunitario a unirse a los 10 que ya han
restringido o han prohibido las
multinacionales chinas Huawei y ZTE de
sus redes de telecomunicaciones 5g ellos
están citando riesgos para la seguridad
colectiva si recuerdas Rodrigo es algo
parecido a lo que ha pasado con la red
social tiktok porque la principal
preocupación europea es que haya un
posible Sabotaje o espionaje pero
Beijing lo ha salido a negar
la comisión europea sigue diciendo que
los proveedores chinos de equipos de
telecomunicaciones como Huawei y ZTE
plantean riesgos de seguridad pero no
pueden proporcionar ninguna prueba Este
es un caso típico de presunción de
culpabilidad China se opone firmemente
el hecho es que Huawei ZTE y otros
proveedores chinos y equipos de
telecomunicaciones han operado en Europa
durante muchos años y no solo nunca han
comprometido la seguridad de los países
europeos sino que también han
contribuido significativamente el
desarrollo del sector de
telecomunicaciones europeo creando
beneficios económicos y sociales
sustanciales bueno no vamos a dejar de
hablar de la Unión Europea al menos
ahora de un país europeo de Francia
porque el presidente Manuel macron
anunció ayudas para las empresas
aeronáuticas que es lo que ha anunciado
Dani pues ha tenido Rodrigo una agenda
bastante apretada hoy el presidente
macron estuvo esta mañana de visita en
una fábrica de motores para aviones de
la empresa azafrán el presidente Manuel
macron reveló que habrá una serie de
subvenciones para desarrollar la
industria aeronáutica baja en carbono
incluidos trescientos millones de euros
al año durante el periodo
2024-2030 esto para apoyar la inversión
en este sector que es uno de los más
importantes renglones de exportación
franceses
producimos alrededor de uno de cada dos
aviones en el mundo Gracias a lo que
hacen ustedes Gracias a airbag gracias a
todo el sector y a sus subcontratistas
eso significa que si sabemos impulsar la
industria francesa podemos ser líderes
en la descarbonización de la industria
de la Aviación y podemos reducir
sustancialmente las emisiones pues
Daniela apretada agenda de Manuel macron
pasamos a Japón porque mantiene su
política ultralaxa en tasas de interés
algo de pedagogía primero la tarea de
los bancos centrales es velar por
mantener el equilibrio entre una
inflación controlada un buen crecimiento
económico y un mercado laboral saludable
pero lo complicado es poder
reconciliar
pero cada Banco Central tiene sus
propias prioridades y la de japonés
apoyar la recuperación a pesar de que es
consciente de que los precios están
subiendo más de lo que se quiere no pasa
lo mismo con Estados Unidos que acaba de
mantener sus tasas ni con la unión con
la zona Euro cuyo Banco Central europeo
ha decidido subir las tasas precisamente
para bajar esa inflación en el caso de
Japón ha venido nadando en contra de la
corriente de sus homólogos en el mundo y
decidió este viernes mantener su tasa de
interés de corto plazo en terreno
negativo concretamente en el es menos
0,1%
Esperamos que la tendencia inflacionaria
aumente a medida que Se incrementa la
actividad económica y el mercado laboral
se fortalece Pero existe una gran
incertidumbre sobre las negociaciones
salariales del próximo año y la
sostenibilidad del crecimiento salarial
por lo que aún necesitamos más tiempo
para cumplir con nuestra meta de
inflación sostenible y estable
a mí y probablemente a muchos
espectadores hay una cosa que no me
queda Clara y es Qué significa tener
estas tasas negativas Pues bueno primero
miremos que Japón ha sido un país
históricamente deflacionario Qué quiere
decir que los precios en lugar de subir
cada año o cada mes bajan Y eso ha
afectado la evolución de los salarios no
Uno pensaría que es bueno que los
precios bajen pero también tiene sus
implicaciones pues su política monetaria
es muy distinta a la de los otros una
tasa negativa implica que a los bancos
que mantienen sus excesos de dinero en
el banco central de Japón ya no se les
va a pagar por ese dinero que tienen ahí
sino que se les va a cobrar de esta
manera lo que buscan es alentarlos a que
conserven esas reservas en lugar de
mantenerlas en el Banco Central para que
utilicen esos recursos para otorgar
préstamos y de esta manera con más
préstamos a la gente pues dinamizan la
economía
Ahora sí yo creo que nos ha quedado
claro Daniela yo creo que sí vamos a
seguir hablando de bancos porque en el
Líbano ha habido otra vez violencia
hacia los bancos Por qué ha habido esto
Daniela Esta es una escena que ya se ha
vuelto muy común en este país decenas de
habitantes de beiruto prendieron fuego a
las instalaciones de múltiples entidades
financieras esta nación árabe vive una
de las peores crisis económicas en la
historia moderna una debacle que empeora
con la tormenta política pues no tiene
presidente desde hace un año pero todos
los detalles los tiene Max Pérez
Gallardo en su informe
los bancos en Líbano arden en fuego en
beirut decenas de ciudadanos
arremetieron contra las sedes de
distintas instituciones financieras a
las que acusan de ofrecerles tasas de
cambio injustas para sus cuentas con
dólares además de retener los retiros en
efectivo de sus ahorros
no estamos exagerando solo estamos
reaccionando ante quienes nos hicieron
daño y nos robaron los ahorros de toda
una vida siempre que tengamos
oportunidad de dañar a los bancos y a
sus propietarios no lo dudaremos no
abandonaremos nuestros ahorros
la crisis económica que vive el país se
suma al estancamiento político que tiene
al Líbano sin un presidente desde hace
casi un año el miércoles el parlamento
no logró su objetivo por elegir un
presidente para el país es el décimo
segundo intento fallido del hemiciclo
libanés nihijada Sur funcionario del
fondo monetario internacional apoyado
por la bancada cristiana
apoyado por hesbola lograron recaudar
los 86 votos necesarios para hacerse con
el cargo una situación que provoca
frustración en los parlamentarios
los resultados afirman la incapacidad
del parlamento desafiar no funciona la
terquedad no funciona tenemos que
sentarnos a la mesa para hablar y
negociar hasta que encontremos un
presidente adecuado
el Líbano enfrenta una de las peores
crisis económicas en la historia
contemporánea una situación que ha
provocado la devaluación de la libra
frente al Dólar de casi el 90 por ciento
Daniela hablando nos vemos más adelante
con más noticias económicas